in minnesota or
in virtual meetings involving vikings
players dalvin cook had been
participating and my understanding is
the team and dalvin cook's
representatives had been trying to work
out a second contract he was not a
first-round pick he felt around two so
he's got one year left on his original
four-year rookie contract they were
trying and trying and trying and they
are trying no more at least not for now
because dalvin cook is going to pull the
plug on the virtual meetings and he
plans to hold out until he gets
as it was reported by adam schefter of
espn which
i think the information came directly
from cook's camp it's not going to come
from the vikings on this cooks people
want a reasonable deal whatever that is
and we'll be talking about what's
reasonable for our an elite running back
who has only so many years to be an
elite running back before he can't be an
elite running back anymore chris
but the bottom line is he's due to make
1.3 million this year we've seen
christian mccaffrey get his second
contract and he had two years left under
contract with carolina panthers
cook wants his and when you consider the
value that cook had to the vikings
offense last year
now is the time to strike it's that same
mindset that ezekiel elliott had a year
ago they need me so i'm going to
withhold services until i get the
contract that i want
yeah that's exactly right i mean i mean
if you're the focal point of the offense
and you play running back in the nfl and
everything that's going on in the
offense is really going through you
why would you continue to play for
peanuts that's the real question and
yeah dalvin cook a guy who's not real
big
extremely explosive but also extremely
aggressive and physical for the size of
which he is
you know 1.3 million dollars just ain't
gonna get it done for a guy in the
minnesota vikings as we know is a
playoff football team
offense is predicated on the run game
gary kubiak so he's got a lot of
leverage here you know i know they got
madison behind him he's a good running
back all of that but dalvin cook without
a doubt is the mvp of that offense and
one of the best running backs in
football you're right it's the same old
conversation mike and really i mean it
it should be
this is what every good running back in
football should do after year three of
their contract
and there's a difference between cook
and christian mccaffrey and ezekiel
elliott because of the fact that that
fifth year option isn't attached to the
back end of the deal and without getting
into the weeds here
as a practical matter
it will take less money
to get cook
a new money average
similar to elliott's and mccaffrey's
because of the fact that there isn't a
significant payment due to him for 2021
and i'll leave it at that we've talked
about new money versus value at signing
but as a practical matter for the
vikings it takes less raw cash
to get to the new money average that we
see from a christian mccaffrey at 16
million ezekiel did 15 million le'veon
bell at 13-1 his deal was signed from
scratch but the top two had two years
left on their deal and that calculation
of new money average factors in what
already was due to be made for cook all
he's due to earn is 1.3 million this
year you put this year into a new
contract with a four-year extension
it's not as hard to get it's not as
expensive to get to 16 or 15 million a
year if that's what he even wants it's
unclear exactly what he wants i've heard
the number 13 million per year thrown
around look he doesn't have that same
dual threat dynamic as christian
mccaffrey but he's still extremely
valuable to the vikings offense he's
missed a lot of games due to injury but
he's still extremely valuable to the
vikings offense and the vikings want to
build around dalvin cook for as long as
he can continue to be a high level
performer chris so they're going to have
to get this worked out or they're going
to have a problem
yeah well and the good thing is dalvin
cook doesn't look like he's going down
the mold of like i want to be the
highest paid running back in football
which he certainly you know could make
an argument for
again you know not that he's better than
christian mccaffrey or maybe he would he
could argue that he could get a little
less than christian mccaffrey is really
what i should say i mean he could do
that i mean we see that with every other
position in football where hey the next
guy's up he's pretty good he's in the
top five conversation he's the richest
guy in the sport cook doesn't look like
he's trying to hold the vikings feet
over the fire to that degree but yeah i
mean i think minnesota with the way
their team structured right now
everything about it you know some new
moving parts on the defensive side of
the ball change their secondary they're
going to have to rely on their offense
this is a big year for their offense and
you know no dalvin cook to your point
mike he's not christian mccaffrey but
they still use him in the past game a
whole lot you know he was second in
receptions last year for that football
team which is still an amazing feat and
he's by far and away the most explosive
player on their offense now that stefan
diggs has gone so when you take all
those things into account you you really
you you go man he's got some leverage
and if they want to be a good offense
and a good football team this year they
need him there in that lineup
and this is the dilemma that any team
with a great running back finds itself
in at some point do you make the big
investment in a second contract and then
brace yourself for the possibility that
you're going to regret it or
do you groom the next man up alexander
madison a guy they drafted out of boise
state in round three in 2019 is a guy
who has shown flashes he's shown promise
yet to really have the opportunity to
take off but
but what the vikings can say to dalvin
cook is hey you're under contract for
2020 will franchise tag you if we see
fit in 2021 and we can always turn the
page to alexander madison they don't
seem to be inclined to do that though
chris i spoke to rick spielman the
vikings gm not long after the draft and
the topic of dalvin cook came up and
based upon the things rick spielman said
it sounds like they want to keep him
around but don't just take my word for
it again as if you ever would here's
what rick spielman had to say in the
days after the 2020 draft
you know we we believe in playing our
paying our own players um those are the
guys that we develop we know them the
best we know what they are from a work
ethic standpoint we know what type of
players they are but we also know how
much they mean out to our community and
how involved they are
and dalvin checks all those boxes he's a
he's a he's a very good football player
but he's even a better human being so
we take the whole picture in and like i
said our philosophy and history has been
developing hopefully we're drafting well
enough and we have to to give long-term
extensions to the guys that have come in
and helped us win ball games
and then fit everything that we're
looking for to build our culture
and one thing they've been very
successful at doing chris is getting
those guys signed to new contracts now
anthony harris is playing under the
franchise tag he's a safety who was
undrafted it's been a pleasant surprise
for the vikings but he said he wants to
stay in minnesota long term various
other key players sign second contracts
kirk cousins is the only guy on either
side of the ball who's basically a
stranger to the organization other than
like a riley reef who was brought in
free agency but a lot of home-grown
vikings players and they reward them and
they usually get it worked out anthony
barr was the one who came closest to
leaving remember he had that deal with
the jets and then he decided right he
didn't have a deal with the championship
because who in the right mind wants to
play for the jets i'm just kidding uh
but uh
maybe i'm not but uh i'm kidding
so so that's what they want to do that's
what they want to do but
ultimately it comes down to how much
cash is it going to take chris and
they're at an impasse now as of a few
weeks ago i think there was some quiet
optimism they would get something done
but right now they're at an impasse and
cook is playing the card that's
available to him under the cba which is
to say the rest of this stuff that we're
doing for the balance of the offseason
is voluntary i'm not going to be part of
it and he does have a right under the
cba
to withhold services in training camp we
hear all the time you signed a contract
you signed a contract and this is the
first time we're saying it in 2020 and
it may be one of the spaces on pft bingo
but there are two contracts the contract
between the player and the team and the
broader contract between the nfl and the
nfl players association players have
rights under both deals the teams have
rights under both deals and dalvin cook
has rights under the broader cba to
withhold services even if he's
technically in violation of his
individual contract with the vikings
remember for your first contract you
don't get to negotiate anything it's all
slotted it's based on where you're
picked it's not like it's an arm's
length negotiation where you adding
incentives and and get more money if you
you know if you start a certain number
no it's all set in stone which makes it
i think even easier for a player to
justify a holdout
yeah no doubt about that and you know
easy to justifiably
have a holdout when you're the most
explosive guy on the offense and the mvp
of the offense and one of the best
running backs in football you know the
big question mike i think is really is
what is that number you're right and
then and then as far as the minnesota
vikings are concerned you know how many
years do they want to commit what kind
of guaranteed money do they want to
commit we've seen of course the running
back market hey christian mccaffrey top
paid guy now the next guy's down
it's not you know a good case argument
for running backs when you start to talk
about ezekiel elliott le'veon bell so
far to me have not lived up either one
have lived up to what they're making
contract wise 15 million and a little
over 13 million david johnson you know
he's there derek henry gets his running
back franchise tag this year so we'll
see it hasn't been a good experiment for
running backs to sit there so far to say
hey teams look i mean the evidence shows
that this is you know a good investment
you get a running back you know they
perform well for a long time you said it
already so it's dangerous that way
um but dalvin cook can't play for 1.3
million dollars especially at that
position in running back in the nfl and
again i think this is going to go on
with every top level running back after
year three of their rookie contract from
here on out and this is what it should
have what should happen but you know
mike i ask you what realistically what
should dalvin cook expect what do you
think he should make i mean he certainly
deserves to be in the le'veon bell
conversation where he's at right now
with 13.1 million
well here's the thing to remember too if
it's a four-year extension on the one
year that's left on his current contract
making it a five-year commitment that's
the limit of my mathematical ability but
if it's a five-year commitment the
question is how much of it is a true
commitment by the vikings is it two
years of fully guaranteed money most
teams will stop at that when it comes to
running backs two years then after that
it becomes a year to year proposition so
the question becomes how much money does
the player want up front to justify
signing on for the extra years beyond
that doing a five-year commitment when
you know that after the first two years
you're at the mercy of the team they're
gonna keep you around if you're
continuing to get it done if you're not
getting it done you're gone that's how
it works and we've seen many running
backs who don't get to the end of that
second contract who don't cash every
check quarterback for the most part
great quarterback is going to cash every
check of every contract with the team
until they get to that point late in the
career where it's time to move on as
we've seen
happen more frequently in recent years
for a running back you're a year or two
into that second contract and the
question begins does he still have it
does he still have it it's that car
crash dynamic how much tread is on the
tires how long can you play at that
level when do you begin to lose half of
a step and not have that explosiveness
that we've seen from dalvin cook in the
footage that's been playing throughout
the show chris so for me the question is
does does he want 27 million over two
years like le'veon bell got now le'veon
bell had to go through a year of the
franchise tag hold out for an entire
season and then he became a free agent
he got that 27 million over two years
fully guaranteed is that what cook wants
and the other dynamic here too is and we
don't know how this is going to play out
with the pandemic and the possibility of
empty stadiums and the salary cap going
down next year that hovers over these
negotiations as well chris
when you have a lot committed to your
quarterback and other key veteran
players on the team
something's got to give and can you
justify tying up that much cash and cap
space over the next two years in in a
running back when you've got alexander
madison there i mean they know him
better than anyone they saw him in
practice we saw some of them in games i
mean it's good is it is it crazy to
think they could just say dalvin if you
want to hold out hold out and we'll go
with alexander madison michael boone and
amir abdullah as our depth chart
no it's not crazy you know they could
get it done
again i i think this will be the part of
the conversation too in the nfl as we go
forward with good running backs after
year three starting to wise up and
realize why would i continue to play
when i'm you know one of the leaders on
our offense as far as statistics and you
know plays made but you know the flip
side of that is the teams i think are
gonna have to start going okay you know
we talked about this during the draft
process you almost got to be in the
draft market for a running back every
three to four years to basically go okay
i'm drafting a running back got him for
three years might have to flip it out
and get a new one three years from now
whatever it may be but yeah well these
type of situations might embolden teams
to start moving on from these running
backs because
i i mean look at the players they're
going to be available here after the
year you know unbelievable it's
unbelievable
yeah i mean if you're a fantasy football
player you i think you pee a little bit
when you see this list the turmoil that
is coming in 2021 when these contracts
expire unbelievable now a lot of these
guys are going to get second contracts
but some of them aren't going to get
second contracts primarily because
number one there's going to be plenty of
free agent running back next year right
and there's always a crop coming out in
the draft every season with full tread
on the tires so what do you do minnesota
viking fan what do you do i want to hear
what you want like what do you think the
proper play is for your team here you
know because you're right rick
spielman's in a tough spot they've
spread some money around because rick
spielman he's one of the best draft
evaluators there is in the nfl so he
keeps drafting awesome linebackers
awesome defense and awesome wide
receivers and they pay him because yes
teams want to keep the players they've
drafted they're homegrown like we heard
him say so this really is a tough one
and i won't lie i think ezekiel elliott
last year scarred me a little bit
uh as much as i we all pounded on the
table for him to get more money you know
the way he played and didn't live up to
expectations and the yards he left on
the field it's it scarred me it scared
me a little bit to throw running
big money out of these running backs
well i think the message for the vikings
is they need to be very candid with
dalvin cook's agents we want to get this
done now if the holdout lasts into
training camp
we are not going to be inclined to pay
you the kind of money you're looking for
because this season ends up potentially
being wasted for dalvin cook if he's not
part of the program so we're hard enough
to get people ready if he's staying away
from training camp in a year when we're
trying to get everybody ready we got
alexander madison and we believe in him
he's grown he's developed we used a
third round pick on him for a reason you
know at the time they didn't know what
dalvin cook was going to be first year
in the league torn acl non-contact week
four they got to the nfc championship
game without him latavius murray was
there maine running back then 2018. he
he he missed games he had a collection
of injuries he he he wasn't you know he
has one year
and look i'm a big dalvin cook guy but
more realistic he's got one year
where he has performed at a high level
the question is can he sustain it and
what is that one year worth from the
standpoint of his next contract and
that's the challenge for the vikings i
don't know what they do but i think
whatever they do they need to make it
clear we got to do it now because it's
in no one's interest for this to linger
into training camp and a couple of quick
a couple of quick cba points that i want
to make because you're going to hear
about this and i want to tell you what
it really means it ultimately means
nothing one of the things you're going
to hear about is under the new cba
if a player
does not yet have his four years of
service toward free agency and he
doesn't show up for training camp he now
automatically loses the year of service
meaning that in 2021
dalvin cook would be a restricted free
agent not eligible for the franchise tag
which is a huge financial difference but
we've seen this time and again the old
deadline was you had to show up 30 days
before the start of the regular season
chris johnson nine years ago he didn't
care
last year cql8 he didn't care remember
everybody in dallas was saying he's
definitely going to show up by august 6.
he'll be there he's not going to give up
that you're afraid no no because here's
the thing
you're holding out for the contract you
don't care about free agency you want
your contract you're going to stay away
until you get your contract so that
doesn't mean anything now it means a
little bit more for cook because he's
one year away from free agency elliot
was two johnson was two but still it's
not it's not that that as it's not as
destructive to a potential holdout as
you would think secondly the fines have
gone up to fifty thousand dollars per
day if you hold out during training camp
but again guys don't care you can still
waive the fines for guys under their
first contracts not for guys under their
second contract that's a new twist but
those things won't matter if he's gonna
stay away he's staying away to get paid
he's not coming back until he gets paid
and that's that chris so those other
things are just details he's staying
away until he gets his contract but i
think it's in his interest and the
team's interest to get this done before
it becomes a training camp hold up
because when that happens
2020 potentially is a wasted season
yeah well you're right it is and dalvin
cook doesn't want that you know as we've
talked about here during the pandemic
and everything else he only got so many
years of you know athletic explosion to
capitalize on that and be an elite nfl
running back so he wants to do that you
know minnesota of course with gary
kubiak taking over at offensive
coordinator of course he wants his
offense to look good and everything to
you know be hitting on all cylinders
i would think mike you know a little bit
like we talked about yesterday you'd be
able to dangle some guaranteed money out
in front of a guy like dalvin cook who
hasn't made a a lot of uh change to this
point you know i know zeke elliott got a
little over 28 million guaranteed at
signing uh christian mccaffrey's what
right at 30 million something like that
if you could find a way to get an
extension with cook and maybe 24 25
million guaranteed something like that
where then it works out to be you know
basically a two or three year deal and
then you reassess from there
i think that could be a win-win from all
sides it doesn't look like dalvin cook
is trying to kill the vikings he looks
like he's just trying to get some money
in his pocket to protect him protect
himself because he's already torn an acl
in the nfl and he does run hard and he
realizes this is the best leverage he's
going to have as an nfl running back
there is no stefan diggs there and he's
clearly the go-to guy of the offense so
you know you do it now or you never do
it and and i think the timing is right
for cook here and if he's not there what
does that mean for kirk cousins because
we have seen cousins thrive when the
running game is working when the running
game is not working kirk cousins does
not thrive puts a lot of eggs in the
alexander madison basket at a minimum
but can kirk cousins get it done if he
doesn't have that dalvin cook threat
i i that's a big question and i don't
want to sit here and just totally put it
all on kirk cousins i question the
offense in general and can gary kubiak
have the type of offense that can spread
the ball out and go oh we don't have a
running back like that we need to do
different things to get the ball to the
receivers in space and do all that so i
have lots of questions there and i think
that adds to the leverage with dalvin
cook though you're right you know
madison's really good don't get me wrong
but again when you only got one good
running back or one proven commodity i
know boone's there but i'm not gonna put
boone in the special category there
quite yet you know hey madison gets hurt
all of a sudden you know you're on to a
list of guys where you don't feel good
about what you might be able to do in
the run game pass game with your running
back it changes your offense all of that
so
it's certainly risky too if you're the
vikings to play the you know we're going
to draw a line in the sand not sign you
dalvin cook and go with the guys we got
that could certainly hurt this offense
in a big way
and if you noticed on the graphic that's
not a misprint 34.7
of kirk cousins throws came from play
action which is the device aimed at
fooling the defense into thinking dalvin
cook is getting the football or some
other running back typically dalvin cook
and and i would say the other third is
bootleg left and the other third is
bootleg right but play action has been
such a big piece of what kirk cousins
has done with this gary kubiak offense
and when dalvin cook is running well it
makes sense freeze the linebackers have
the corners maybe peeking into the
backfield a little bit and it gives your
guys a chance to run past them and it
sets up a big play potentially so if you
don't have a threat at running back all
of a sudden that's not as effective
chris that that's what the vikings are
facing this is a dilemma for the vikings
and it's a dilemma for dalvin cook
because i don't think he wants to join
that list of guys
who played the game
and got his money and then when it was
time to literally play the game he
couldn't play like he used to i think
that he's smart enough to recognize from
the lessons
shown to him by others that there's a
chance he plays this in a way where he
has a down year and i don't think he
wants to do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports